this episode has been supported by
lambda labs dear fellow scholars this is
two minute papers with károly on alpha
here let's talk about a great recent
development in image translation image
translation means that some image goes
in and it is translated into an
analogous image of a different class a
good example of this would be when we
have a standing tiger as an input and we
ask the algorithm to translate this
image into the same tiger lying down
this leads to many amazing applications
for instance we can specify a daytime
image and get the same scene during
night time we can go from maps to
satellite images
from video games to reality and more
however much like many learning
algorithms today most of these
techniques have a key limitation they
need a lot of training data or in other
words these neural networks require
seeing a ton of images in all of these
classes before they can learn to
meaningfully translate between them this
is clearly inferior to how humans think
right if I would show you a horse you
could easily imagine and some of you
could even draw what it would look like
if it were a zebra instead as I'm sure
you have noticed by reading arguments on
many internet forums humans are pretty
good at generalization so how could we
possibly develop a learning technique
that can look at very few images and
obtain knowledge from them that
generalizes well have a look at this
crazy new paper from scientists at
Nvidia that accomplishes exactly that in
this example they show an input image of
a golden retriever and then we specify
the target classes by showing them a
bunch of different animal breeds and
look in goes your golden and outcomes a
pug or any other dog breed you can think
of and now hold on to your papers
because this AI doesn't have access to
these target images and it had only seen
them the very first time as we just gave
it to them it can do this translation
with previously unseen object classes
how is this insanity even possible this
work contains a generative adversarial
Network which assumes that the training
set we give it contains images of
different animals and what it does
during training is practicing the
translation process between these
animals it also contains a class encoder
that creates a low dimensional latent
space for each of these classes which
means that it tries to compress these
images down to a few features that
contain the essence of these individual
dog breeds apparently it can learn the
essence of these classes really well
because it was able to convert our image
into a pug without ever seeing a pug
other than this one target image
as you can see here it comes out way
ahead of previous techniques but of
course if we give it a target image that
is dramatically different than anything
the AI has seen before it may falter
luckily you can even try it yourself
through this web demo which works on
pets so make sure to read the
instructions carefully and let the
experiments begin in fact due to popular
request let me kick this off with Lisa
my favorite Chihuahua I got many
tempting alternatives but worry not in
reality she will stay as is I was also
curious about trying a non-traditional
head position and as you see with the
results this was a much more challenging
case for the AI the paper also discusses
this limitation in more detail you know
the saying - more papers down the line
and I am sure this will also be remedied
I am hoping that you will also try your
own pets and as a fellow scholar you
will flood the comment section here with
your findings
strictly for science of course if you
are doing deep learning make sure to
look into lambda GPU systems lambda
offers workstations servers laptops and
the GPU cloud for deep learning you can
save up to 90% over AWS GCP and azure
GPU instances every lambda GPU system is
pre-installed with tensorflow
pi torch and Karis just plug it in and
start training lambda customers include
Apple Microsoft and Stanford go to
lambda labs comm slash papers or click
the link in the video description to
learn more
big thanks to lambda for supporting two
minute papers and helping us make better
videos thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time